what's up guys so over at corridor
digital we do a lot of things a lot of
people know us for our visual effects I
do a lot of sound design and music a lot
of things both on and off set but one
thing that we aren't still doing for
every single video regardless of what it
is is directing directing is actually
one of the biggest tasks that we face
with every single video and so today I'm
going to share a few tips and things
we've learned over the years that might
help you be a better first time director
or just a director in general here we go
having strong respectable leadership on
set is tricky it takes patience a very
clear vision of what you want and good
communication it's not always about how
good your decisions are it's about the
fact that you make them clearly and
communicate them clearly with the rest
of the team that's how you get stuff
done protip don't always stick to the
script I'm not really sure what the
script is right now but all I can tell
you is that some of the best decisions
and best moments we have on set come
from unscripted moments people are
coming up with ideas constantly you have
a bunch of people all creative minds
there to help you so if something works
and feels good don't worry about
breaking the script just make sure you
have a plan to cover it up if it creates
problems later pro tip if you like a
director style try studying that when
you watch their films you can learn from
it film sets are very chaotic hectic
places sometimes and you have maybe
people asking you all questions and need
answers but sometimes you need to just
take a moment make a clear decision and
that's okay even though there's a rush
sometimes or you're trying to get things
done
it's much better to take your time and
make a good decision then rush it and
make a bad one so always keep that in
mind oh so communication is key when
working with people and as a director
you want to make sure you can do that
clearly you can do that either through
eight a shot list before coming to set a
storyboard or you can go as far as
making a previz pre-visualization a
rendering of what you want to do but
regardless each of these ways helps
communicate the idea of the final vision
and the final goal and you may want to
consider picking one of these three is
your method of choice when you write a
scene
think of it from the cameras point of
view but oftentimes directing and
operating the camera at the same time is
not ideal it can lead to you focusing a
lot more on your framing and your
camerawork than the actual performance
which is what matters at the end of the
day so try to reach out to somebody and
find someone else to help you shoot
because you leave them at times
protip you can use your fingers to set
up shots or you can get really high-tech
and use a viewfinder this little tool
has cool settings that simulate
different focal lengths aspect ratios
and all the other things you get when
you look through a camera so when you're
on set use this to plan out your shots
time is a very finite and valuable
resource and you will often find that
you don't have a lot of it the best
thing you can do is look at what's
giving you the best return for your
hours spent and you will often find that
spending a lot of time on something will
start yielding very little change in
quality that's a sign that you have
passed the point of diminishing returns
and you should put that product out
there for everybody to see produce it
avoid getting into fights or arguments
with people if you have an issue with
someone take them aside talk about it
privately you don't want to lose your
cool as the director it's very
unprofessional
pro tip you're gonna be extremely busy
on set so make sure you stay hydrated
you don't need the best gear in the
world you just need something that lets
you tell the story and do it quickly as
long as the audience isn't distracted
you're good protip everyone's actually
really confused on set all the time so
rather than be demanding like a boss and
telling you exactly what to do do better
yeah you need to nurture people you have
to be more like a parent or a coach that
is generally what's worked best for us
and you should try to do the same don't
sit don't do an actor stuff for them so
avoid trying to tell them how to do a
scene and instead try to let the actor
understand why they're doing a scene
acting is a very unique and strange
profession and it's very hard to make
sure you respect what an actor needs to
get into the headspace with the scene
often that can be space it could be
quiet it can be loud ask them what they
need and the more they trust you as a
director the better their performance
will be
now we'd all love all the time in the
world to finish our project but that's
not the best way to progress and learn
you need deadlines and that's one of the
biggest things we've learned after
making YouTube videos for so long every
single time we finished one and execute
one we have something to learn from
because it's done we can sit there we
have reactions and we have our own
critiques so make sure when you are
working on something don't stagnate it
pick a deadline and move on that's the
best way to figure out what to do next
[Music]